TO ASSESS THE 21ST CENTURY
PENTECOST.
ARE YOU SAVED?
BACK IN THE TEMPORAL WORLD, IT
IS DAY FOUR OF THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL CONVENTION.
IT IS TIME TO CONSIDER WHAT WE
HAVE LEARNED SO FAR.
WE SEE AN AWFUL LOT THIS WEEK,
WASH ELIZABETH WARREN PROMISE TO
BRING PEACE TO INDIAN COUNTRY, A
LADY CALLED IN FROM THEIR
$11 MILLION SUMMER HOME.
WE MET GENDER-TRANSCEND INTO
MERMAID QUEEN-KING WHO DREAMT OF
A WORLD WITHOUT POLICE OR
PRISONS.
POST-MAKEOVER SANDY CORTEZ
NOMINATE A MAN SHE REFERRED TO
SEE MYSTERIOUSLY AS "BERNARD
SANDERS" FOR PRESIDENT.
WHAT IS IT ALL MEAN?
ONE THING IT DOES NOT AMOUNT TO
IS A COHERENT IDEOLOGICAL
FRAMEWORK OR LOGICAL GOVERNING
STRATEGY.
THAT’S ABOUT THE ONLY THING THEY
AGREE ON.
JOE BIDEN HIMSELF DOESN’T HAVE
PARTICULARLY STRONG VIEWS ON
ANYTHING THESE DAYS EXCEPT MAYBE
AND NO ONE IN THE ROOM LIKES
KAMALA HARRIS AND NO ONE IN THE
ROOMWHATEXACTLY DO THESE PEOPLE
COMMON?
THEY ARE ALL DEEPLY AND
PERSONALLY UNHAPPY.
THIS IS THE COALITION OF THE
MISERABLE.
IT’S HARD TO KNOW PRECISELY WHAT
WENT WRONG FOR THESE PEOPLE.
SOME OF THEM ARE MAD AT THEIR
FATHERS, FOR OTHERS LIFE DIDN’T
TURN OUT THE WAY THEY HOPED.
IT CAN MAKE PEOPLE BETTER.
MANY OTHERS ARE SIMPLY VICTIMS
OF THEIR OWN AFFLUENCE.
BEING RICH FOR TOO LONG TENDS TO
DESTROY PEOPLE FROM WITHIN
PARTICULARLY WHEN THEY DIDN’T
EARN IT, THEY BECOME GUILTY AND
RESTLESS AND INSECURE.
WHATEVER THE COST, YOU CANNOT
TAKEANYONE MALADJUSTED GROUP AT
DNC THIS WEEK.
LAST NIGHT, THE SCHEDULE IN APPE
SINGER CALLED BILLIE EILISH.
THE FIRST THING YOU NOTICE IS
SHE’S VERY UNHAPPY.
WHATEVER SHE’S GOT GOING ON IN
HER PERSONAL LIFE, YOU DON’T
WANT TO BE PART OF IT AND WHO
KNOWS WHAT IT’S REALLY ABOUT,
SHE PROBABLY DOESN’T KNOW.
MOST OF US DON’T REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT AILS US BUT FOR
THE PURPOSES OF LAST NIGHT’S
EVENT IT DOESN’T MATTER.
LIKE ALMOST EVERYBODY IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, BILLIE EILISH
HAS DECIDED THAT DONALD TRUMP IS
HER CORE PROBLEM.
>> YOU DON’T NEED ME TO TELL YOU
THAT THINGS ARE A MESS,
DONALD TRUMP IS DESTROYING OUR
COUNTRY AND EVERYTHING WE CARE
ABOUT.
WE NEED LEADERS WHO WILL SOLVE
PROBLEMS LIKE CLIMATE CHANGE AND
COVID, NOT DENY THEM.
LEADERS WHO WILL FIGHT AGAINST
RACISM AND INEQUALITY.
IT STARTS WITH VOTING AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP AND FOR JOE BIDEN.
WE ALL HAVE TO VOTE LIKE OUR
LIVES INTO THE WORLD DEPEND ON
IT, BECAUSE THEY DO.
>> Tucker: DONALD TRUMP IS
DESTROYING EVERYTHING WE CARE
ABOUT.
PERIOD.
THAT RIGHT THERE IS THE MESSAGE
OF THE DNC THIS WEEK.
THE MESSAGE IS NOT "JOE BIDEN
CAN IDENTIFY HIS OWN WIFE BY
SITE AND IS THEREFORE FIT TO
LEAD THE COUNTRY."
IT’S NOT "KAMALA HARRIS IS A
VERY SINCERE PERSON WHO IS
THOUGHT THROUGH THE ISSUES THAT
MATTER."
IT’S NOT EVEN "VOTE FOR US AND
OUR PROGRAM WON’T MAKE THE
COUNTRY BETTER."
NO.
IT’S MORE COMPELLING.
"YOU’RE UNHAPPY, SO ARE WE, IT’S
ALL DONALD TRUMP’S FAULT SO KICK
HIM OUT."
REAL LIFE BY CONTRAST IS
COMPLICATED.
IF WE ARE BEING HONEST ABOUT IT,
ALL OF US WE IMPLICATED IN OUR
OWN FAILURES TO A MUCH GREATER
EXTENT THAN WE CARE TO ADMIT BUT
THAT’S THE THING.
AT THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
CONVENTION, YOU DON’T HAVE TO
ADMIT IT.
YOU DID NOTHING WRONG.
YOU ARE BLAMELESS, IT’S ALL
DONALD TRUMP’S BALL.
WATCH CHIEF WARREN COME ALIVE
FROM INDIAN COUNTRY.
>> DONALD TRUMP’S IGNORANCE AND
INCOMPETENCE HAVE ALWAYS BEEN A
DANGER TO OUR COUNTRY.
COVID-19 WAS TRUMP’S BIGGEST
CHEST.
HE FAILED MISERABLY.
THIS CRISIS IS ON DONALD TRUMP
AND THE REPUBLICANS WHO ENABLE
HIM.
ON NOVEMBER 3RD, WE WILL HOLD
THEM ALL ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Tucker: SEE?
AT THE CORONAVIRUS TO THE LIST
OF HIS CRIMES.
IT’S ALL THERE.
WHEN HE WASN’T STUFFING YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD’S MAILBOXES INTO
THE BACK OF HIS SUBURBAN, IT
TURNS OUT DONALD TRUMP WAS UP
LATE IN HIS BASEMENT LAB MIXING
UP LETHAL BAT PATHOGENS WHICH
EAT UNLEASHED ON AMERICA FROM
HIS OWN PERSONAL WET MARKET.
YOU SHOULD SEE WHAT HE DID TO
THE NURSING HOMES IN THE STATE
OF NEW YORK, IT WAS AWFUL.
GIVE THAT MAN POINTS FOR ENERGY.
DONALD TRUMP IS SO COMMITTED TO
MAKING YOU UNHAPPY THAT HE
RARELY SLEEPS.
YOU LOOK SKEPTICAL.
HOW COULD ONE MAN ACHIEVE SO
MUCH GLOBAL EVIL IN A SINGLE
24-HOUR DAY?
THERE JUST ISN’T TIME.
WHEN DID HE HAVE A CHANCE TO
CALL VLADIMIR PUTIN?
THAT’S A FAIR POINT, IT DOES
SOUND UNLIKELY.
ON THE OTHER HAND, IT’S EASIER
THAN THE ALTERNATIVE
EXPLANATIONS.
LET’S SAY YOU LOST A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION THAT BY
ANY MATTER YOU SHOULD OF WON,
YOUR HUSBAND WAS THE PRESIDENT,
IN THE END IT TURNED OUT THAT
YOU WERE TO ENTITLE, TOO OUT OF
TOUCH, VOTERS JUST DIDN’T LIKE
YOU.
IT WOULD BE HARD TO ADMIT THAT
TO YOURSELF.
IT WOULD BE EVEN HARDER TO ADMIT
IT TO OTHERS.
YOU MIGHT JUST PREFER TO BLAME
DONALD TRUMP.
HE MUST’VE CHEATED, SOUNDS LIKE
SOMETHING HE WOULD DO.
>> I WISH DONALD TRUMP KNEW HOW
TO BE A PRESIDENT BECAUSE
AMERICA NEEDS A PRESIDENT RIGHT
NOW.
REMEMBER BACK IN 2016 WHEN TRUMP
ASKED, WHAT YOU HAVE TO LOSE?
WELL NOW WE KNOW.
OUR HEALTH CARE, OUR JOBS, OUR
LOVED ONES.
OUR LEADERSHIP IN THE WORLD AND
EVEN OUR POST OFFICE.
DON’T FORGET, JOE AND KAMALA CAN
WIN BY 3 MILLION VOTES AND STILL
LOSE.
TAKE IT FROM ME.
SO WE NEED NUMBERS OVERWHELMING
SO TRUMP CAN’T SNEAK OR STEAL
HIS WAY TO VICTORY.
>> Tucker: SEE?
TRUMP STOLEN ALONG WITH THE
MAILBOXES AND THE PAY PHONES.
OF COURSE HE DID.
DONALD TRUMP IS SUCH A BAD
PERSON AT THE TRUE SCOPE OF HIS
DIABOLICAL AWFULNESS IS HARD TO
DESCRIBE.
MAYBE IMPOSSIBLE TO DESCRIBE.
MAYBE IT’S BETTER TO NOT EVEN
TRY TO DESCRIBE IT.
IT’S LIKE WHEN YOUR GRANDMOTHER
GOT SICK, NO ONE WANTED TO SAY
WHAT IT WAS, THE DISEASE WAS TOO
SCARY.
TRUMP IS THAT BAD.
THE GOOD NEWS IS, COMPARED TO
DONALD TRUMP, EVERYBODY ELSE
LOOKS GOOD.
EVEN THE WORST PEOPLE,
ESPECIALLY THE WORST PEOPLE AND
THAT’S THE BEAUTY OF IT.
LISTEN TO HOW THEY ARE
DESCRIBING TEDDY KENNEDY AT THE
DNC.
>> I HAVE ADMIRED JOE BIDEN
SINCE I WAS A SENATE INTERN IN
1974.
CELEBRATE WOMEN’S RIGHTS AND
WORKING FAMILIES.
>> Tucker: UNCLE TEDDY’S
COMMITMENT TO WOMEN’S RIGHTS.
THE SAME UNCLE TEDDY WHO FLED TO
THE SCENE OF A DRUNK DRIVING
ACCIDENT AND LEFT A YOUNG WOMAN
TO DROWN SLOWLY IN THE BACKSEAT.
THE SAME UNCLE TEDDY WHO SHARED
THE HARVEY WEINSTEIN SCHOOL OF
DATING.
AND YOU’RE STARTING TO SEE THE
APPEAL OF THE MESSAGE HERE, ARE
YOU NOT?
EVERYONE GETS OFF THE HOOK
EXCEPT FOR DONALD TRUMP.
AND PEOPLE WHO LOOK LIKE
DONALD TRUMP ARE EVIL, TOO,
GUILT BY RESEMBLANCE PAID >> IT
WAS ALL ABOUT REPRESENTATION.
MY LITTLE MEL HEART FELT SO FULL
LAST NIGHT.
>> TODAY WITH DAVID AND JOHN IS
THE FIRST TIME I SEE A WHITE MAN
LIKE IN EIGHT HOURS OTHER THAN
JOE BIDEN LAST NIGHT AND THAT’S
OKAY, THEY’VE HAD 240 YEARS OF
REPRESENTATION, THEY’RE GOING TO
BE OKAY.
>> Tucker: SO THIS IS HOW BAD
HE IS, ANYONE WITH THE SAME SKIN
COLOR IS DONALD TRUMP IS
REPULSIVE.
SO DISGUSTING, SO REPUGNANT TO
GAZE UPON, THE CNN ANCHOR IS NOW
REFRESHED.
A SPOT TREATMENT IN SEDONA,
THAT’S A HOT TOWELS.
KEEP IN MIND, NOTHING YOU’VE
JUST HEARD HIS RACISM.
NO, OF COURSE.
IF YOU SAID THAT ABOUT THE CNN
ANCHOR, OBVIOUSLY STILL WOULD
BE.
BUT THE CNN ANCHOR ISN’T
DONALD TRUMP, IS SHE?
NO, SHE’S NOT SOMEONE WHO LOOKS
LIKE DONALD TRUMP, IS SHE?
NO.
OKAY, SO IT’S FINE.
JUST LIKE DROWNING A WOMAN IN A
CAR, IT TOTALLY DEPENDS.
WAS TRUMP AROUND?
IT’S ALL ABOUT CONTEXT.
EVENTUALLY KAMALA HARRIS TOOK
THE STAGE LAST NIGHT.
"WHEREVER ELSE WE ARE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, WE ARE
DEFINITELY NOT DONALD TRUMP AND
THAT’S ENOUGH SO JUST VOTE FOR
US, EVERYTHING WILL BE FINE."
>> SO I THINK WE NEED TO ASK
OURSELVES, WHY DON’T THEY WANT
US TO VOTE?
WHY IS THERE SO MUCH EFFORT TO
SILENCE OUR VOICES?
AND THE ANSWER IS BECAUSE WHEN
WE VOTE, THINGS CHANGE.
WHEN WE VOTE, THINGS GET BETTER.
>> Tucker: THERE IT IS RIGHT
THERE, THAT’S THE LINE OF THE
NIGHT.
"WHEN WE VOTE, THINGS GET
BETTER."
VOTE FOR US AND THINGS WILL GET
BETTER.
SHE’S NOT TELLING YOU HOW
THEY’RE GOING TO GET BETTER, WHY
WOULD SHE?
JUST VOTE.
PUT US IN POWER AND YOUR LIFE
WILL INSTANTLY IMPROVE.
THAT’S ALSO THE PROMISE THEY’VE
BEEN MAKING FOR DECADES AND FOR
DECADES PEOPLE HAVE BELIEVED
THEM.
DEMOCRATS NOW CONTROL NEARLY
EVERY MAJOR POPULATION CENTER IN
THIS COUNTRY.
SO THE QUESTION IS, HOW ARE
THOSE PLACES DOING?
HAVE THINGS GOTTEN BETTER IN SAY
CHICAGO, DETROIT, BALTIMORE,
BIRMINGHAM, IN THE CITY.
WE WILL LEAVE THE REPORTING OF
THAT TO YOU.
GOOGLE THE NAME OF ANY MAJOR
AMERICAN CITY AND SEE HOW LIFE
IS LOOKING FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
LIVE IN THOSE PLACES RIGHT NOW.
THEY DID WHAT THEY WERE TOLD,
VOTED THE WAY KAMALA HARRIS
WANTED THEM TO VOTE.
DID LIFE IMPROVE?
THAT’S THE BASIC QUESTION AND
MAYBE THE ONLY QUESTION THAT
MATTERS.
DEMOCRATS HATE IT WHEN YOU ASK.
WHEN YOU PRESS THEM AND LET YOU
KNOW, THIS MAY COME AS NO SHOCK,
DONALD TRUMP IS DESTROYING
THINGS AND PLACES THEY’VE
CONTROLLED FOR GENERATIONS.
THEN THEY CHANGED THE SUBJECT.
OFTEN THEY BRING UP A PLACE
CALLED SELMA, A SMALL CITY IN
THE STATE OF ALABAMA, FAMOUS
BECAUSE THERE WAS A
CONSEQUENTIAL CIVIL RIGHTS MARCH
THEIR 55 YEARS AGO THIS SPRING.
WE HEAR A LOT ABOUT THE MARCH
BUT YOU NEVER HEAR ABOUT HOW THE
STORY ENDED.
PEOPLE IN SELMA VOTED AND GOOD,
THAT WAS THE POINT OF THE MARCH.
AND THEY VOTED FOR DEMOCRATS.
HOW DID THAT TURN OUT FOR THEM?
SELMA IS NOW THE POOREST CITY IN
ALABAMA, THE MOST DANGEROUS
PLACE IN THE STATE.
IT HAS THE HIGHEST UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE.
MORE THAN 40% OF THE PEOPLE WHO
LIVE IN SELMA ARE POOR, THEY ARE
IN POVERTY.
THAT’S A TRAGEDY.
IT’S AMAZING THERE IS A CITY
LIKE THAT IN THIS COUNTRY.
DOES DEAN KAMALA HARRIS CARE?
HAS SHE EVER MENTIONED REAL LIFE
SELMA?
PROBABLY SHE HAVE HASN’T DONE
HAS KAMALA HARRIS DONE TO MAKE
SELMA BETTER?
YOU KNOW THE ANSWER.
PROGRESSIVE DEMOCRATS TOOK
CONTROL OF SELMA AND THAT WAS
THE END OF THE STORY BECAUSE
TAKING CONTROL WAS THE WHOLE
POINT.
THE LIVES OF THE ACTUAL PEOPLE
WHO REMAINED THERE DIDN’T
MATTER.
AND THEY STILL DON’T.
BUT TO KAMALA HARRIS, THIS IS
THE BLUEPRINT FOR THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY.
>> AND THE EXCESSIVE USE OF
FORCE BY POLICE AND IN OUR
BROADER CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM,
THERE IS NO VACCINE FOR RACISM.
WE HAVE GOT TO DO THE WORK.
FOR GEORGE FLOYD, FOR BREONNA
TAYLOR, FOR THE LIVES OF TOO
MANY OTHERS TO NAME, WE’VE GOT
TO DO THE WORK TO FULFILL THAT
PROMISE.
OF EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER LAW.
BECAUSE HERE’S THE THING, NONE
OF US ARE FREE UNTIL ALL OF US
ARE FREE.
>> Tucker: YEAH, OKAY.
WHAT’S INTERESTING IS WHAT
KAMALA HARRIS DIDN’T SAY IN THAT
SPEECH.
AT NO POINT DID SHE MENTION ANY
OF THE PEOPLE DYING AS SHE WAS
SPEAKING, THE BEATINGS, FOR
EXAMPLE, THAT TOOK PLACE, THE
ASSAULTS GOING ON AS THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL CONVENTION
PROGRESS THIS WEEK.
THEY ARE NOT IMPORTANT.
THE OTHER DAY IN MANHATTAN, A
RETIRED NYPD SERGEANT WAS
VICIOUSLY BEATEN AND ROBBED ON
CAMERA TO MY CAMERA, CITIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE FALLING
APART IN REAL TIME.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE DNC AFTER
PARTY THIS WEEK, WATCH.
>> [BLEEP] [WHISTLE-BLOWING]
[SHOUTING]
>> [BLEEP] >> Tucker: THOSE
ARE REAL PEOPLE.
THEIR LIVES MATTER, NO MATTER
WHAT THEY LOOK LIKE, NO MATTER
WHO THEY VOTED FOR, THEY ARE
AMERICANS, THEIR LIVES MATTER
AND THEY ARE BEING HURT AND IN
SOME PLACES KILLED BUT THEY
WEREN’T MENTIONED, THEY HAVEN’T
BEEN MENTIONED ALL WEEK, WHY IS
THAT?
BECAUSE THE POLICIES THEY ARE
PUSHING ARE IMPLICATED IN THE
VIOLENCE YOU’RE WATCHING.
NOR ARE THEY MENTIONING WHAT’S
HAPPENING IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT
NOW.
THEY ARE ROLLING BLACKOUTS.
WE NEED A GREEN NEW DEAL, THE
DEMOCRATS TELL YOU.
OKAY, WHAT WILL THAT LOOK LIKE?
WELL, THERE IS ONE STATE IN THE
UNION THAT IS CLOSER TO A GREEN
NEW DEAL THAN ANY OTHER.
IT’S CALIFORNIA AND THANKS TO
ITS GREEN ENERGY POLICY,
CALIFORNIA IS SUFFERING HISTORIC
POWER OUTAGES IN THE MIDDLE OF A
HEAT WAVE.
THAT CAN KILL PEOPLE.
FOR ANOTHER THING, IT’S NOT A
FIRST WORLD SITUATION, WE ARE
SUPPOSED TO HAVE ELECTRICITY AND
WHEN OUR BIG ESTATE DOESN’T IT
TELLS YOU THERE’S BEEN MASSIVE
AND PROFOUND, POSSIBLY CRIMINAL
MISMANAGEMENT.
WHO DID THAT AND WHY?
SHOULDN’T WE BE INTERESTED IN
FINDING OUT?
NO MENTION OF IT LAST NIGHT.
>> WE’VE BEEN WITHOUT POWER 60
PLUS HOURS SINCE FRIDAY NIGHT.
>> AT LEAST HALF A DOES IN
MEDICAL DEVICES THAT NEED POWER,
ALL OF THEM HELP TO KEEP HIS SON
ALIVE.
DURING OTHER POWER OUTAGES HE
WOULD GET ADVANCED EMAC ADVANCE
NOTICE BUT NOT THIS WEEKEND.
>> THIS PARTICULAR OUTAGE, WE
GOT NO HEADS UP, NO INFORMATION.
>> THOUSANDS OF RESIDENTS IN
SAN JOSE LOST POWER OVER THE
WEEKEND AS EARLY AS FRIDAY
NIGHT.
THIS MAP SHOWS THAT THOUSANDS
MORE ARE STILL AFFECTED.
>> Tucker: MOST VOTERS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE DEMOCRATS, THIS
IS NOT IN ANY SENSE OF PARTISAN
POINT.
CALIFORNIA WILL VOTE FOR KAMALA
HARRIS IN NOVEMBER, NO QUESTION
ABOUT THAT.
IT’S A QUESTION OF HELPING
ACTUAL PEOPLE, NOT JUST
REPEATING MINDLESS PLATITUDES,
TELLING US THE SAME TWO STORIES
ABOUT POLICE BRUTALITY.
NOBODY DEFENDS POLICE BRUTALITY,
NOBODY IS IN FAVOR OF IT BUT IF
YOU KEEP TALKING ABOUT THE SAME
STORIES IT GIVES US THE SENSE
THAT YOU ARE INTENTIONALLY
IGNORING WHAT’S ACTUALLY
HAPPENING.
WHICH IS THE CONSISTENT TO
LOWERING THE STANDARD OF LIVING
FOR ACTUAL AMERICANS, MILLIONS
OF THEM.
SO YOU SHOULDN’T BE SURPRISED IF
YOU CONTINUE TO IGNORE THINGS
PEOPLE ACTUALLY CARE ABOUT THAT
PEOPLE MAY NOT BE THAT EXCITED
ABOUT YOUR CANDIDACY DESPITE HOW
THEY FEEL ABOUT THE GUY YOU ARE
RUNNING AGAINST.
IN THE CASE OF KAMALA HARRIS,
THAT MEANT THEY HAD TO MAKE
PEOPLE UP.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS, THIS IS,
THEY HAD TO DUPLICATE SOME OF
HER FANS AFTER THE ADDRESS.
IT WAS HARD TO FIND A ROOM FULL
OF PEOPLE ACTUALLY CLAPPING SO
THEY JUST INVENTED SOME PEOPLE
OUT OF THIN AIR.
IT’S GOOD ENOUGH OR MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL, IT’S GOOD ENOUGH FOR
THE DNC, TAKE A LOOK.
SO IF YOU’RE WONDERING WHERE THE
GENUINE SUPPORTERS ARE, THEY MAY
BE WANDERING AROUND LOOKING FOR